following this topic very closely taking
a lot of heat for it but telling the
truth regardless congressman thanks so
much for coming on tonight so you know
it's not even a personal attack on biden
and i certainly don't mean to be
disrespectful to anyone in his present
condition but the united states the
future of the country hangs in the
balance and i don't understand how the
democratic party can continue to support
someone who's completely out of control
i i think what we're seeing here tucker
is you're focusing on his comments about
regime changes it was not a gaf at all
president biden just said out loud what
the aims and objectives of his
administration's policies are which is
regime change in russia to get putin out
of power
and you know they're they're doing so
through
using the primary weapons of economic
warfare they're doing so by waging this
modern day siege against russia
you know isolating containing destroying
their economy starving the russian
people in the hopes that the russian
people or the military will rise up and
revolt and overthrow their government
and get rid of putin and the reason why
they're lying about this to the american
people tucker is they know that we are
sick and tired of our country waging
regime change wars we remember how
costly and devastating these wars in
iraq and libya and syria and others have
been and we reject them wholeheartedly
so if they were to come out and tell the
truth their polls would tank even more
than they already are and their politics
uh would suffer and and that's really
where we have to
i believe you completely
that
clearly they they want that but what
comes after killing people is relatively
easy building things is really hard so
this is a real country with 140 million
people living in it huge energy reserves
putin goes then what have they thought
that through
i mean the answer to that is clearly no
and and this isn't this isn't just my
opinion we have history to look for to
the answer to this question in every one
of these regime change wars uh we've
seen how the answer to the question what
happens next who takes charge after you
topple that dictator uh what weapons
will they have under their control they
never have an answer to that question
and what we're seeing play out before us
is following that exact same track
record only dange more dangerously so
because the american people are smart
enough to know that a regime change war
against a nuclear-armed russia is very
different from any other that's been
waged before and will result in in
disastrous consequences that that go
beyond anything we could even imagine
yeah i thank you for i mean these people
who couldn't keep track of the own their
own dangerous biological agents they
were funding in ukraine they have no
idea where they are obviously
they're going to keep track of 6000
nuclear weapons i don't think so so you
are saying things that almost nobody
else in the public sphere is saying
you've said recently that facebook mark
zuckerberg has been suppressing
your message here's here's the clip of
you explaining
when people try to type my name into the
search box on instagram or the discover
box uh my account does not show up i'm
also getting a lot of reports from
people who are trying to at me at my
name at tulsi gabbard and mention their
instagram stories or posts and they're
getting a warning that says this account
has posted false information
so we're fighting for freedom in ukraine
but we can't speak freely in this
country that's kind of the conclusion
i'm coming to
yeah that pretty much that's the
conclusion is uh you know big tech is is
acting as this dictatorship telling the
telling us what we're allowed to say
what we're not allowed to say you know
the thing that they're saying they're
i'm spreading misinformation once again
there's no evidence there's no examples
there's no notice from them saying hey
this is what you're saying that's false
right absolutely none of that so it
comes down to if they don't like what
you're saying if you're shining a light
on the truth then you're going to be
shut down or silenced
yeah well i'd like to have some freedom
here i think that would be our first our
first concern
great to see you tonight thank you so
much
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight